[Music]
[Applause]
Brian windhorst ESPN NBA senior writer
and uh figured we'd have Wendy on to
talk about
the new policies here load management
give me the highlights on this Brian how
long has this been in the works
I think uh well they've been trying to
deal with this for a year or two but
really what's happening is now that they
have the collective bargaining agreement
done which they got done uh in the
spring and summer they finalized it in
the summer they're thinking about the TV
deal if you want the honest assessment
and the the TV deal when you're trying
to sell your wares even though there is
robust interest they're going to do very
well on it
um you don't want Star players sitting
out and so that's what they're focused
on that is a driving factor and why
they're enforcing this now and they're
negotiating over this next year
um and saying hey they're trying to
really sell I mean anybody can sell the
the playoff games everybody wants in on
those
but you're trying to sell Wednesday
night games in December and you know
potentially Friday night games or
Thursday night games in um in February
and if you can't count on your star
players to play in those games their
value may be uh somewhat less and so
that's a driving force that's although
it's interesting Adam Silver is
basically with his comments saying that
uh they don't any longer buy these
science that resting players means fewer
injuries
um I question whether or not he would
say that if they weren't almost also
negotiating a TV deal but it is relevant
that he said that all right how does it
work how does it work well
I don't know
okay how does it not work well
well here's the thing
what Adam was saying is that not only
were healthy players resting players who
were not injured being you know put on
the bench for National TV games but he
felt that it was almost like a certain
stature that you reached
um you know
um certain players in the league achieve
a certain things where they get to
control certain things on a team
when they might travel where they might
stay the ability to have a personal
security guard or personal trainer come
from outside the team and work with the
team
there's certain perks that are afforded
to a star player what Adam basically was
saying is
that what he had noticed and the league
had noticed is that there was a stature
that came with you're such a big star
that we're going to arrest you and he's
just felt that that basically he used
the words that got away from them and
now when you talk to players and agents
about the resting thing what they have
said is that it's not the players who
are going in and saying boy that knee is
sore boy my back is stiff I'm gonna take
this uh this game off that it's the team
that says listen we've been tracking you
with our tracking software and it
indicates your load is 17 higher than
desired and so we're going to sit you
tonight and you know they hit the ping
pong ball right back so this is not
being applied to to uh players it's
being applied to teams the fines that
are in place are not going to go to the
player they're going to go to the team
so we'll see it's possible that a team
is like we'll pay the fine to protect
our player and I mean I think that's a
trial in there that's going to be you
know examined throughout this season
okay but let's say Steph Curry
has a sore hamstring
can they prove that he doesn't have a
sore hamstring if he's going to sit down
it's a very logical question so what
they're saying is is that if they
suspect
Shenanigans that's my word they can
assign an independent doctor to go in
there and you know stretch Steph Curry's
hamstring out and say boy that does seem
sore now will that actually happen
no but are you suggesting that we could
see an increase in back soreness or
uh uh and I remember back in when I
first started covering the NBA uh they
would have to
you don't even realize have 12 players
active at any one time and you had to
put the the non-players on the injury
list so the guys who weren't playing
they would put on the injury list
everybody in the league had achilles
tendonitis or knee tendonitis so could
we see a an incredible increase in
Achilles tendinitis yes we could in
theory though
uh
if the if the league expects that
suspects that you're you know not doing
not being honest they could investigate
it and find you the strange thing about
this Dan not strange the interesting
thing is that they have designated 50
players as quote unquote star players
and they their metric on it is
interesting if you were an all NBA
player or an All-Star in any of the last
three years you're quote unquote star
players
but there's a whole bunch of teams that
don't have any of these quote-unquote
star players so if you're the Detroit
Pistons you can rest anybody you want at
any time and you're playing against a
team potentially on the second night of
it back to back it's got to play their
Stars especially if it's uh involved in
a certain set of circumstances Victor
webinyama because he's a rookie he
applies to nothing if the Spurs want to
play him 27 games uh there's no fine
feathers so there's donut holes in this
strategy and I don't earn this plan and
I don't think I think there's more
fine-tuning to come he's Brian windhorst
ESPN senior NBA writer did the Spurs
start this trend many many many many
years ago when they sat guys when they
were going into Miami
yeah and the reason that was so
surprising was they sat three guys all
in one game for a finals rematch on TNT
that Charles Barkley had been brought in
to call on the sideline TNT had
designated this game as one of its
um big games in the early season and
Popovich went right into punt formation
and sent the guys back to San Antonio on
a Southwest Airlines flight but not
mistaken they said go to the airport
Orlando Airport stand in line with all
the kids wearing Mickey hats and go to
San Antonio and David Stern was so
incensed that he find the Spurs 250 000
before the end of the first quarter no
investigation no whatever David Stern
issue the fine which you know this was
2000 I think 13. so 10 years ago
250 was you know it was not it was a lot
more than it is today and um but he he
because David recognized right out of
the gate he had to knit this in the butt
and so that's what's and I remember that
there was a game last year in Cleveland
um
it was I believe a Friday night game uh
and it was Warriors at Cavs when the
Cavs
announced their schedule
this was one of the Prime games that
they put on their schedule the defending
Champion Warriors come in and there was
obviously many different
um of these iterations that happened
throughout the season but this was our
member red letter and they charge a lot
more for those games you know uh those
are you know game premium games and the
night before the Warriors went into
overtime in Boston and as soon as that
happened I was like I remember I had a
friend going to the game I was like I
got bad news for you I don't think
they're gonna play and sure enough they
got there Curry clay Draymond I can't
remember Wiggins play they all sat and
so yes that's what they're doing but
they're also doing it because I don't
remember if that game was on National
Television but there are instances where
that has happened on National Television
um I remember last year one game uh Joel
embiid and um and Nikola yokic had a
great game uh in Philadelphia embiid
made a mission of it dominated jokic it
was awesome and then when they played
again in Denver and beats that arrest
and I know as somebody who's heavily
involved in the league I wanted I was
very excited to see that game it was you
know this close to being a finals
preview uh the Sixers didn't get it done
but they could have been there and you
know he sat and that's what they're
they're trying to sell those games for
billions of dollars and so they need to
be look if Joel embiid's knee is really
hurting him and he can't play can't play
but you know they're they're looking to
to eliminate the word rest from the
injury report what about ticket
Insurance I've been uh preaching this
for a few years that if you're gonna buy
tickets uh that you pay a premium but
you're buying you know insurance that
these star players are going to play is
is there a way that they I don't know if
the NBA gets involved in this if it's
like seat geek or something like that
but could you see where
because you know you have these
Christmas Day games you're buying
tickets for your son or daughter to go
to these games and Steph Curry's coming
to town and I know there's no insurance
there that these guys are going to play
that company would have declared
bankruptcy with jets tickets this year
alone right probably in all honesty uh
while they're anecdotally is these these
remarkable stories uh of you know the
Cleveland fans getting short shrift in
that case
I don't think the league cares as much
about the ticket holders as they do
about the TV deal oh boy um because I I
um I mean I think that they want to help
the ticket holders too I don't think
they don't I don't I don't think it's
zero but I think the primary reason for
this happening now
is that now is when they're negotiating
the TV deal and I think it's a progress
in the right direction I uh have no
science or no data to say that it's
prevented injuries or whatever some of
these rest games but I personally think
the devaluing of the regular season
is a um serious issue for the NBA and if
you continue to send a message to your
fans and to your partners that the
regular season is not important they're
going to believe you eventually so again
they're trying to sell something that's
very important and they're trying to
reinforce that it is important I think
that's what's going on good to talk to
you again Brian thanks for joining us
thank you Dan Ryan windhorst of the
Mothership